[Music]
with your purpose in life still to tell
others to better people's life - for us
to have a more of a weakened state and
just help me peppers it's just have a
great time and to see the world to
figure out my purpose in life and then
if in the work I'm not sure yet
oh my purpose in life is to bring others
happiness with every interaction I have
with someone so I hope I made you smile
back there is to learn and help others
to learn by telling stories making them
laugh once you make them laugh and you
can make you can teach anybody anything
if you can make them laugh because you
eat somebody giggling and that that is
that they're most capable of learning
when they're giggling so I get them
laughing and then that's next thing you
know they're learning something from as
I do have two masters degrees
from Berkeley traveling I'm trying to
find myself trying to figure out who I
am inside make a lot of money and retire
to touch in effect
people that
and to help people that's my purpose do
anything I can to keep someone safe like
say I've decided to be a police officer
because I want to make a difference in
what people think about police officers
and show that we're actually here to
help my purpose in life is a bunch of
kids
just trying to make you go live wife and
raise good children for the world to
keep going
[Music]
you know I'm not you know some superstar
like I don't even have like a college
degree you know but like where I work
like I have the ability to like help
people get through the minute and the
second and maybe an hour you know what I
mean and the rest is up to them you know
that's all I'm doing
I work at a UMass Medical Center and
Worcester Mass it's called emergency
mental health I'm just a tech and I get
to see like all the gems of society
we're just trying to best not to like
kill themselves or somebody else people
right on the edge you know what I mean
and sometimes I can help them sometimes
I just got to get out of the way I think
my purpose is to spread awareness for
childhood and ovarian cancer I travel
all across the country and I sing for
kids
[Music]
and I try to give an approach and the
strength to keep fighting moment trying
to find creative
The Pursuit of Happyness
it's uh just the artist
spread joy and be present with life of
people and allow them to shine and be
seen and I'll have them to see me just
for them to smile you know I want to
give them some of the smile about you
know I don't really know that much about
what they're going through but you know
how to show them what I get you know
just even busting
[Music]
for the cow saw that Valentine's Day
[Music]
to have fun and the hello to exhaust is
many possibilities that I can with this
body it's possible
to become enlightened and to reciprocate
that out for for others to be blooming
language essentially that's that's my
purpose and and it really is that deep
for me it's not I'm not just saying that
to give you some you know Miss
Congeniality answer
to try to make it back to my Heavenly
Father I had my Mormon so I definitely
believe in
annika lifestyle so yeah
to become a successful again so my kids
won't have to live a hard life
my boyfriend calls me amethyst so I have
this ring I meet broken people and
really random times I guess and I kind
of just become part of my life and I
think that has a lot to do - I was
raised I'm a military brat I've traveled
all over the world
in the new girl over and over and over
would always felt at home regardless I
think my life practice is to heal people
to bring people together spread word
better myself try to look out for my
grandkids that I got now so I you know
help them out as much as I can before I
know something happened to me cuz I'm
old I don't know I mean this is basic
but I guess just live life to the
fullest and travel as much as you can
because I feel like there's so much to
see and do out there I just recently
became a vegan and I would like to
become a voice for animals they're you
know they're suffering constantly you
know I think my purpose it's hard you
know I mean I don't think people are
born knowing their purpose I think is
something that I like come about like as
an epiphany or some sort of way that you
would like like come into like you know
what I mean like a lot of people have to
have like something like real life
change in order for them to realize what
the whole purpose of life is you know or
towards everybody else's pedal hard to
tell you that was discus I don't think I
hit that part of my life through purpose
it's a music you know my purpose maybe I
want to change somebody's life by the
beatbox
music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- mm mm mm - time to - can I hand you
the camera right now and have you ask me
any question you like sure okay so you
want a sweet spot it's already recording
I just put on my face and push this
button once it should focus and whenever
you're ready you can ask me whatever you
want can you cast me whatever you want
whatever you want oh and then you can
ask whenever you ready you can make it
fun just not political okay all right so
one question is
the anticipation is killing right that's
how I feel when you walk this to you
with that camera why are you doing this
all right what is your name Sariah what
do you hope to accomplish with this why
are you here
just like in general like words the
purpose of life as a human being why are
you dream how do you have the confidence
to talk to people like that other day
one thing you change about your life
what inspired you to make films can you
make a living doing this how would you
define consciousness what's your dream
why did you choose to make this film
well my question for you is what is your
theory about something today is this or
do they not tell me a funny joke that
you know or a joke you've picked up a
long long since been here in Venice is a
misconception about you what do you feel
is the most important human
characteristic to have
[Music]